you know my friends I look at this
photograph and I have to ask myself you
know I think I've seen this somewhere
before people marching in the street for
justice but I know it's not the same
photograph and I would have seen because
I wouldn't take my Oaks to be a police
officer until 1989 and I've been in the
business for over 25 years and
identifying as an african-american woman
I know things have gotten better but
even as I learned about public safety
I wondered if what I was doing on the
street was hurting or harming the
community and I often wondered if you
know how did they perceive me this woman
in uniform but there's one thing that I
knew I knew there was a way that we
could do this probably different or
better a way that preserved dignity and
guaranteed justice but I also knew that
police could not do it alone it's the
co-production Public Safety
there's a lot of history with us you
know we know loss the relationship
between the african-american community
and the police is a painful one often
filled with mistrust it is been studied
by social scientists it has been studied
by government all both promising you
know hopeful new ways long-term fixes
but all we want is to be safe and our
safety is intertwined and that we know
in order to have great relationships and
relationships built on trust that we're
gonna have to have communication and in
this Advent in this text of the world
that we've got going on trying to do
this with social media it's a very
difficult thing to do we also have to
examine our current policing practice
and we have to set those things aside
that no longer serve us so in New York
that meant stop question and frisk that
meant really holding up the numbers as
opposed to relationships and it really
didn't allow the officers the
opportunity to get to know the community
in which they serve but you see there is
a better way and we know it's called
co-production so in the 1970s Elinor
Ostrom came up with this theory really
called co-production and this is how it
works
you bring people into the space that
come with separate expertise and you
also come with new ideas lived
experience and you produce a new
knowledge and when you produce that new
knowledge and you apply this theory to
public safety you produce a new type of
Public Safety and so in New York it
feels like this it is called building
relationships literally one block at a
time and it's build the block so this is
how it works you go to build the block
dot in YC you put in your address and up
pops location date and time of your
neighborhood meeting the important part
of this is it you got to go to the
meeting and once you go to that meeting
there of course will be in YPD along
with officers and other community
members what's important about bringing
now the lived experience into this space
to produce new knowledge is that we have
to have a new way of delivering it so
the new way of delivering it is through
what we call the neighborhood
coordinating officers or NCOs and so
also in this meeting are the NCOs the
what we call 911 response cars sector
cars detectives all of us working
together to collaborate in this new way
to reduce crime and what's interesting
about this is that we know that it works
so for example in Washington Heights at
a community meeting there was a bar up
in Washington Heights and the neighbors
were complaining about Al Qaeda noises
so in their conversations with their NCO
they talked about
you know sound barriers different ways
to sort of approach this is there a
different way we can direct traffic and
of course now they have relatively
quieter bar nights so another you know
issue that always comes up in
neighborhoods speeding how many of you
in here have ever had a speeding ticket
raise your hand oh hi oh come on there's
more than that New York right so those
are other issues that are brought to the
NCO so speeding with the NCOs dues they
collaborate with the Department of
Transportation they look at issues such
as speed bumps and signage and all types
of things and when we come together to
create this different type of policing
it also feels different the
co-production of public safety also
means that officers need to understand
the history and the power of their
uniforms they're gonna have to set aside
old historical narratives it does not
serve them well and that means they have
to learn about implicit bias implicit
biases or shortcuts the brain makes
without us really knowing at there's
stereotypes that often influence our
decision making and so you can imagine
for police officers you have to make
split-second decisions can be a very
dense mental decision-making point
that's why the NYPD along with other
departments throughout the United States
are training all of their officers and
implicit bias they have to understand
that learning about their implicit
biases having good training tactics and
de-escalation and understanding how it
impacts your decision-making makes us
all safer we also know how officers are
treated inside the organization impact
how they're going to behave with the
community at large this is critical
especially if you want to have a new way
forward and we know that we have to care
for those folks that are on the
frontline and they have to recognize
their own trauma and in order to do that
us as leaders have to lift them up and
let them know that the narratives of
being strong men and women you can set
those aside and it's okay to say you
need help and we do that by providing
peer support employees assistance mental
health services
we make sure all of those things are in
place because without it it's a critical
component to the co-production of Public
Safety equally as important is that we
also have social issues that are often
laid at the feet of law enforcement so
for example mental health and education
historically we've been pulled into
those spaces where we have not
necessarily provided public safety but
have enforced long historical
legislative racial desegregation we have
to own our part in history but we also
have to have those folks at the table
when we're talking about how do we move
forward with co-production but
understanding this we also have to
understand that we need to have voices
come to us in a different way we also
have to recognize that the community may
not be willing or ready to come to the
table to have the conversation and
that's okay we have to be able to accept
that by acknowledging it it also means
that we care for the community's health
and for their resiliency as well that's
another key component we also have to
acknowledge that those folks that are in
our community they're here they do want
to do us harm we also have to recognize
that we have community members who did
not get the benefits of a long ago dream
we also have to acknowledge that we have
put faith in a system that sometimes is
broken hoping that it would give us
solutions for better but we cannot walk
away because there is a better way and
we know this because the NYPD's
neighborhood policing philosophy is
grounded in the co-production of public
safety in order for us to move forward
together
it's our family our friends and for our
health we have to make sure that we
focus this way and in order to do that
there are three fundamental ideologies
that we must all agree to are you ready
I'm sorry one more time are you ready
now that's better alright the first one
there's no more wallowing in the why we
know why we must move forward together
there's no more us versus that number
two we must embrace the lived experience
and our histories and we must make sure
we never go back to a place where we
cannot move forward and number three we
must also make sure that truth and
telling facts is painful but we also
know that no action is no longer
acceptable and agree I'm sorry I can't
hear you agree alright so we do know
that there is a better way and the
better way is the co-production of
public safety thank you
[Applause]